Eric Osborne can you manager at bungee
so we're here in vegas at PSX showing
off a little sony exclusive strike here
it's coming up in the dark below hits
tuesday this is the undying mind it's
sort of a rip through the black garden
in Reverse so some of this will look
familiar of course as we get to the boss
you'll see a bunch of unfamiliar looking
stuff and it really cool encounter
towards the end nice to use out the back
you want to take the time and look
around but otherwise you just start
throwing down with some sex all right uh
no I've got I've got some guys back at
the ranch some guys at the ranch I guess
you'd ranch we got a dude ranch ranch
pretty much they destiny dude ranch just
playing the raid over and over right now
awesome I'm Harburg they're in love this
game if sending questions they couldn't
be I'm just gonna sweet anytime Harry's
yeah I'm in dude questions I'm just
going to London I you if you can
that's great sweet not that's great or
if you have anything you want to point
out in as we play just yeah I think the
thing you noticed you think the things
you'll notice as he's playing here is
because he switches between weapons
you'll see some new legendary so
probably see a new exotic or two he's
got murmur here which is a pretty cool
weapon archetype it's a it's a fusion
rifle but it can do either our course
solar damage you can sort of switch that
back and forth on the fly as he sees fit
depending on how he wants to play or
what enemies he's fighting okay speaking
of like Sony exclusive stuff huh we kind
of learned that sir is going to sell
upgrades or Sony exclusive items yeah
how's it gonna affect Xbox owners they
won't see it so just like the
PlayStation content it won't appear in
their inventory so you have to worry
about sir being populated with a hot
food if you're not able to get it just
take it one slot or anything like that
ok and then how does the nasty with it
you have to be dirty pool how does his
upgrades exotic armor work like does the
light level give this did much in the
same way so pretty much any of the
exotic armor or weapons so say you have
a fully level icebreaker right now your
level 30 in your rock in the hard mode
that's your go-to right yeah when one
and if Sir has that for you or if you
get in a drop you can get it from a
regular draw from a strike from an
Engram many of the
you can get here sort of exotic bounties
as well so all those systems are still
in place and they'll always drop the
latest version so you've got your fully
upgraded icebreaker when you look at the
new version of it and you're choosing
whether or not you want to trade in your
old one for it it'll automatically have
a higher level straight out of the gate
and so we've done some things to too
it's just patently better straight away
and then as you upgrade it we wanted to
make it a little less painful to do so
if you've got your ice breaker you don't
want to go back through all the Senate
materials again yeah so we've taken
those away and you can get those through
just standard materials relic iron
spirit blue and that sort of thing and
we've also needed the path to those a
little bit more ubiquitous so you're
just playing a lot of pvp you can get
crucible marks and spend those on
materials now so we want to get players
a little bit more easier avenues to get
into the later stages on the upgrades
but we also want to make it really clear
like what you're trading in your exotic
it's a better choice like you're
choosing to do it because that weapon
looks better I think some of the
feedback out of the game we were a
little bit slow to get the exotic shard
news out there which is definitely our
mistake we should have handled that a
little bit better but I think the
difference between the communication on
the exotics shark thing upgrade for that
is like if you were to walk up to sir
without any knowledge it looked like a
cool upgrade right for us if you have
any or that I think a lot of people
believe that what we're going to do is
sort of erase their exotic progress
which is not the case if you've got a
full of ice breaker right now you should
take that into crotas end it will be a
very viable very powerful weapon for you
it's still awesome right but you might
get during that ready to drop with the
second version which will be
cool and speaking of exotics are you
adding them and maybe you can answer
this are you Adam in over a more steady
period of time or they only going to
drop with his expansions as they come
out so we get tweaked the raid oh you do
content yeah I mean it's definitely
something we can do and we're looking at
doing so our job right now on sustaining
support is to sort of look at what
players are doing evaluate feedback look
at player data you know look at the
behavior what would this player actually
saying and I'm what are they doing and
then trying to find ways to deliver new
experiences for them so i think i heard
banner is a really good example of a way
that we can take content that we thought
would be cool and turned out we were
totally wrong and so that we went we
were able to revise it in a pretty quick
order and get that back out there for
people and then section everybody really
we were able to get we were able to
listen to the feedback and respond and
do a couple of things right we were able
to not only make a higher barrier field
this thing to live it up to the sort of
promised that it held we are also able
to revise some of the the end game for
player so if you were looking for though
those gauntlets to get to level 30 or
those boots you could get them through
Lord salad as opposed to just the rage
so big over time we're sort of learning
as as you know we we had a lot of great
ideas I thing a lot of move hand out a
lot of things are working really well in
destiny we've got a lot of players
coming in where three months in sm
Tuesday in December night this will be
our 12th update to the game so we're
pretty proud of the pace that we're
keeping up oh we're not done we're gonna
keep addressing feedback we're keep
listening the players more bounty slots
more or less very weapons what have you
so it's good it's quite the fun process
and speaking of like that sort of
with content as you can add new content
like the baltinglass raid yep it's not
going to stay relevant and you it's like
how are you guys going to keep that
relevant it's like the new gear is
seemingly outdated soon as this
expansion Rob's yeah for like that right
gears out in it right so like how do you
motivate people to keep doing well it's
not necessarily outdated right like
right here from both the glass is still
going to be good here right like your
vision of confluence or your husband's
vengeance oh they're still gonna be
really great weapons for you to use the
raid the new rain will certainly have
better gear for you go after and to
covet and just sort of go out there and
try to try to win over but you know the
bulk last raid hopefully players are
playing it not only because the gear is
good because because the the rewards are
good but because it's really fun and
really challenging and it's I mean for
me personally it's one of the most fun
I've had and in destiny right why ray i
think IM trying out so there's there's
there's that you know sort of just the
fun experience that you can have so i
don't think we want to discount that but
there are definitely some things we can
do with all of our activities to and
things will have to do as we progress
through and level up characters and
other stuff too to cater to both people
who are at the end stages of leveling
and new players yet again right like a
new player will they want to do that rig
versus stepping stone for you know just
yeah yeah they can go in there and then
get level 30 s and get some cool buns
out of that they can have fun and get up
to speed on the mechanics get the raid
group going get the communication
channels going before they try to step
up into the harder crotas end right so
awesome and i think going you know going
forward and longer term in the future we
just have to continue to find ways to
make all the content feel really viable
you know some of that can be shaking it
up with stuff like iron banner right
which doesn't change the base underlying
content
it's sort of a systematic wrapper that
makes it feel different changes the
power in the way the sandbox work so
there's a lot of fun things we can do on
to tweak and make experience and skill
new okay and then I've got a cheeky
question cheeky when are we getting
Janeiro races what you can do Sparrow
racing right now but we talking like
formal racing is you have an idea that
has come up at the studio and there are
like dozens and dozens and dozens of
cool idea so you know part of the
process of sustained is figuring out you
know what's the most bang for the buck
what's the right feedback to go after an
address you know how do we deliver the
experiences that players want and the
race is definitely one of the things
that has come up as a topic so we'll see
if cool and there are those that shifty
no promises answers no sure but you know
had to ask I guess sounds like an
awesome yeah I've seen I've seen a you
know like racing league spin up where
people are sort of creating their own
courses based on landmarks we definitely
saw people doing tricks on the sparrow
so they'll use like great like skating
Ramson Bowl so if you buy the dark below
or if you've already purchased it if the
rear include the tumblers Pharaoh which
is specifically designed to you know
highlight that emergent behavior let
players have a little bit more fun it's
sort of designed after like a BMX bike
right it's got the
you can do no handers and Superman's and
kick-out don't kind of fun stuff Bertie
it down
so the you mentioned there's going to be
new vanguard and crystal weapons and
armor are they going to be fashionable
specific by the armor in the dark below
so right now I can definitely confirm
the vanguard and a crucible armor for
legendaries factions are definitely a
space we've heard people ask us to flush
out a little bit more so going for that
it's definitely something that we're
looking at I'm just gonna get my dead
orbit shader there's one about hardened
mode for the raid a new raid yep it's
not gonna be able till January I guess
spin them yep said yeah so the core raid
the normal rate will be available
immediately so if you're looking to do a
server first you're in the states to
probably want to take the next day off
just going to be at 1am start for you
yeah you're in London or Germany you
probably want to take that day off but
you'll be starting early in the morning
and running through so I our
expectations there's gonna be a few raid
groups trying to let's do it as fast as
they possibly can and part of the rate
the hard mode is he deserve learn the
mechanics first get up to speed on the
normal raid and it will that up and
we'll have course the rewards he can get
only from the heart
as it spins up in January so it's time
for players to get their gear up is the
time for them to learn the new puzzles
and crotas end that sort of figure out
what they need to do to be it does that
allow you guys to react to that first
the first great footage coming through
you're like oh maybe we should think
that far hard mode sure absolutely so I
think the hardwood ray is one of the few
pieces of content that we can sort of
you know pull back the starting line so
see what people are doing in the normal
raid well but that isn't the core intent
it really is just have a normal rate up
and going and then open that up later on
down the line last time out at launch
what we did was we sort of helped the
rate the whole raid back yeah and that's
to preserve the sort of starting line
experience right the trophy is to get
there the server first so given the
given that we were going to enable it
now simultaneously at launch we didn't
want that server first to be dictated by
a time zone or download speed right the
big trope you want to make sure
everybody knows in advance or reset
their time to explore photos and
everybody knows what they need to do
every set their team ready to go and
they can also start and hit that hard
road harden would rate at the same time
like firing to Ghana out of the starting
gates um people who kind I just went
through the campaign maybe by themselves
or only do if you go up I didn't really
get too hard for into it everything is
dark below ground it's gonna grab their
attention maybe help them get the 30 oh
well it faster than they
would have had to or like yeah so all
they call the news legendary gear and
exotics will help them get to 30 and
climb up we'll do some more stuff with
iron banner of course to help get them
suited up for a rate if that's something
they're going to tackle I mean but I
think we're also obligated to think
about you little sheep in the cherry it
would have put a people they're up there
are plenty of people out there who
aren't gonna try a raid right like our
goal is to make it appealing for
everybody to build an experience it's
really hard and challenging that anybody
in a competent group can with some
tenacity and with some coordination
conquer yeah but we know that some
players are going to you know fit into
the kind of activity that they want to
experience if you're a competitive
multiplayer player you're going to play
the crucible and not much else right and
so we've got to find ways to you know
and I think we have found a lot of ways
we have to find more ways to make those
experiences just feel really rewarding
long term for those players as well you
know so one of one of our goals for the
game is to make content a wide offering
of content that a lot of players can
experience and most players that come in
we find play a little bit of everything
right yeah what was it called omnivores
they start beefy from all the little
cuisines we have on offer all the
different activities but we know there
are some players that isolate and just
want to play us a specific activity they
go get hyper focused on the raid will
get hyper focused in crucible and that's
okay we have to make sure that those
players are happy while they're playing
our game and they're getting served in
the same way somebody playing the rate
is so you know within those updates if
you go back to the patch notes you know
the Dozen updates that we've shipped
today you'll find fixes for every
activity out there
as well I said this strike basically
pulls you in Reverse through some of the
terrain you've already experienced in
the story campaign but marks the real
first return to the black garden we also
have Pantheon in our crucible
multiplayer stable which is set on a
black garden as well it's a really cool
palette nice a mixture of sort of
organic rock shapes crumbling sort of
environment with the effects technology
and so this is the undying mind the boss
ago that comes through the portal
helpful in ads precursors and effects
that you might have seen in the rain you
saw the two sort of spires forming at
the beginning to activate this gate so
we're doing some fun cues like that
hearken to the rain sort of thematically
and then there's a storyline as you're
playing through the hive you'll see some
things that are are familiar from the
rate itself as well some fun hop on
mechanics and things designed to make
some of the encounters a little more
interesting and challenging as you play
through
yeah we're also able to have a little
bit more fun with the weaponry select
murmur that's his diffusion rivalry
currently has is one of the rewards to
get we're competing the story missions
with theirs as a high beam weapon
there's other high beam weapons and its
experience of twelve of this one like it
says you can you can move from different
damage types at a will we can actually
go into cover and change that to thermal
damage if you wanted to so if there's
like a solar burn on on this you could
turn that over and do a lot more damage
and they also have some slightly
different underlying statistics as well
so one's better for close range of one's
better for long range and that's sort of
why he's able to use this at medium
range it's sort of almost I've fallen hi
theme to the weapon as well I tend to
rush you a little bit more so it's more
like a shotgun up close and Paula tend
to be a little bit this is so it's a
little bit more rangy it's also we're
doing some other fun stuff with some
exotic like quests throughout the rest
of the story missions to sort of extend
them out you know your core story
missions a Harris will give you but you
also give you bounties throughout the
world to fight high or about that stitch
into the strike about a stitch into the
red to make them feel like they're
somatically connected to her story we're
having a lot of fun with that
Oh
the black garden remains here among the
light but the vex will never cease until
the birth is is restored and we must
keep it here until we can understand its
origins
you